by 2020 China plans to give all of its
1.4 billion citizens a personal score
based on how they behave so some people
with low scores are already already
being pushed if they want already being
punished rather if they want to travel
nearly 11 million Chinese people can no
longer fly and 4 million are barred from
trains next week the program will start
expanding Nationwide Ben Tracy is in
China with what's behind the government
scoring system Ben this sounds like
scary stuff good morning
good morning the government here says it
is trying to purify Society by rewarding
those who are trustworthy and punishing
those who are not so like the credit
score that most Americans get for how
they handle their finances Chinese
citizens are now getting social credit
scores based on everything from whether
they pay their taxes on time to how they
cross the street
when Leo who recently tried to book a
flight he was told he was banned from
flying because he's on the list of
untrustworthy people Leo was a
journalist who was ordered by a court to
apologize for a series of tweets he
wrote and was then told his apology was
insincere
I can't buy property my child can't go
to private school he says you feel
you're being controlled by the list all
the time
and the list is now getting longer as
every Chinese citizen is being assigned
a social credit score a fluctuating
rating based on a range of behaviors
it's believed that community service and
buying chinese-made products can raise
your score fraud tax evasion and smoking
in non-smoking areas can drop it if a
score gets too low a person can be
banned from buying plane and train
tickets real estate cars and even
high-speed internet
it's a good thing this woman says there
should be punishment for people who
can't behave China's growing network of
surveillance cameras makes all of this
possible the country already has an
estimated 176 million cameras and it
plans to have more than 600 million
installed by 2020. it can recognize more
than 4 000 Vehicles shoe Lee is the CEO
of sense time one of China's most
successful artificial intelligence
companies it has created smart cameras
for the government that can help catch
criminals but also track average
citizens this knows every person every
bike every car every bus you can tell
whether it is an adult a child a male or
female in several big cities in China
including here in Shanghai the
government is even tracking jaywalkers
cameras record them going through
intersections zero in on their face and
then publicly shame them on nearby video
screens can moskin has studied China's
economic and political culture for more
than three decades he says how the new
scoring system truly works is kept
secret and could be easily abused by the
government how far into people's daily
mundane activities does this go well I
think that the government and the people
running the plan would like to go as
deeply as possible to determine how to
allocate benefits and also how to impact
and shape their behavior
now there are upsides for people the
Chinese government considers trustworthy
they can actually get better interest
rates at Banks they can get discounts on
their energy bills and China's largest
online dating site reportedly even
boosts the profiles of people with high
social credit scores Nora incredible
then Tracy in Beijing thank you it's the
ultimate version of Big Brothers
watching no thanks yeah yeah own
chilling yeah I think so too
imagine that I mean we do have in major
cities we do have cameras everywhere
yeah but if you're jaywalkings were
marking you down right you're jaywalking
I still expect to be able to fly yeah so
don't take that away or allow your kid
to go to private yes yes that's a great
great story to see what's happening
there thank you Ben